my people are either do business and
then miss out massively on their
personal brand yeah or they have a
personal brand and I have a following
and they're pushing it pushing it but
they're just got zero business behind it
they don't monetize off of it everybody
can be an influencer I know this is
something that you believe really
passionately could you all you've been
telling all of the guys in the office
everybody has a brand but you said that
you'd rather have a personal brand yeah
the money in the bank yeah and a
personal brand is more powerful than
money in the bank yeah it's kind of cool
yeah I'm so true Samuel Leeds has got it
has got his own I say here's I speaking
I speak like that because Sammy Williams
is two things though Samuel leads the
person which is me and then the Samuel
leads the brand yep and as it happens
Samuel leaves the person and Samuel is
the brand are very similar which of the
same person sometimes that's not the
case yeah sometimes you've got the brand
and the person and they're very
different but no one really knows what
some celebrities are like in real life
yeah they know the Browns you know
someone people meet me in real life man
you've quite actually the same as the
Browns I was starting over again from
scratch literally with a new identity
yeah let's say let's say someone wipes
or if I went to another country mm-hmm
okay where no one knew who I was
I would so build the Samuel he's been
back or the job how would you go about
that I would have no documents log
everything I'm doing some people just
document their family that ourselves as
a mom
they just dock you in their life but if
it's interesting and if it is valuable
then then people will start was to not
follow it blogging is a form of telling
people what you're doing but I would
just tell the world wrongdoing in every
possible which were could so if I was
starting to get in Australia I'd just be
like Samuel Leeds starts again in
Australia Samuel Leeds views his first
house in Australia 7yz puts forward that
his first offer in Australia everything
will be a story
everything will be documented when I
bought my first house and Leeds buys his
first albums Sam he leads us to kick out
his first tenant second house third
house 4050
Samuel is financially free and then I'd
be going to the newspapers with the
stories I'd be going to the I'll be
trying to make something newsworthy
trying to make things interesting
resonating with people putting it out
there because I know that in business
people think you need a lot of money you
do not need a lot of money in business
and an LRU something you make it sound
too easy
you make it agree to it listen man I
don't make it sound too easy it's just
on the businessperson and I know that in
order to make money what money comes
from people and the thing you need is
you need people to know that you exist
yeah if people know that you exist then
you can make money from but from a
service or a product or a joint venture
agreement because people know you people
trust you you have a reputation you can
have a million pounds in the bank but if
you have it but no one knows who you are
if you haven't got the there's the three
things that you need to do to make money
you need knowledge you need network
people and you need money
my name is the least important because
you can get money from people when
people know who you are because your
networks yeah Stephen was saying that a
lot of his business comes through his
personal brand and not actually his
business I think that's kind of like the
same with you like you kind of built
your brand and that's kind of where
everything's coming from like the whole
business is built off your personal
brand it is now but I only realized
about personal branding about four years
ago okay when I started building my
business I would network yeah I had a
CRM system I would get business cards
put them on my CRM system drop emails
out and stuff like that and I knew that
you have to get people in front of you I
think what I didn't know is the power of
online branding so in in in the property
kind of tight-knit circles and community
people knew others it's like young guy
who's do really well in property he's
out I was even I was just putting myself
out I was doing I was doing crazy stuff
like I was renting rooms out for free
because that gets staggers attention
he's renting rooms out for free if
you're a landlord he's managing you
probably know Froy was that on em was
that something you would documented or
just me no I don't document it I didn't
realize at the time I didn't have anyone
to tell me that I needed to where do you
think you would be now without YouTube I
think I'll be way less known but you can
of course you can have a personal brand
of art being today yes having a personal
brand is basically just being well-known
or being famous people were famous long
before the incident yeah personal
anything a personal brand is just a
person I think Jeff besos movie and it's
a person that quoted it it was like a
personal brand is what people say about
you and you're not in the room so the
way people think about you yeah so
everyone has one yeah so everyone has
one but everybody was brand new yes and
it's like actively working on it like
some people will just be like I don't
have a branded off brand so they won't
work on it but I think that's kind of
like a neat naive way to think about it
like as soon as you own the fact that
you have a personal brand it means you
can start working to almost make your
personal brand what you want it and I
think it's nothing about because I guess
some people would think oh maybe you
know see that as maybe like a fake thing
like all your manipulating kind of who
you are but it's more just like putting
your best foot forward and being like
these are the best things about me and
this is what I want to be known for
rather than and they're not only just
talking about that but becoming that
yeah so saying who do I want to be yeah
and then becoming that person about
everybody I believe everybody's a leader
yeah everybody's a leader of unless you
just literally don't know anybody in
your isolated in your house in your own
but if you've got kids you're a leader
yeah you know everybody is a leader but
it's just a case of acknowledging that
and then and then being aware of it and
saying actually everything I do
as a consequence sometimes good
sometimes bad and I need to really think
about my decisions before I do them
because people are watching and people
are following and people are copying and
then being responsible so my personal
brand I have a personal brand people
know that I exist
yeah and the question is what do they
think about me and and how how is my
brand and how am i known for so um yeah
I think it's very important as you say
everyone has a personal brand if you do
it for the fun of it and that's the only
reason you're gonna stop doing it at
some point because it will become unfun
yeah it will become unfun you have days
when you'll be like oh man I don't shoot
under the YouTube video so initially
have a business behind it you're just
gonna give up at some point because as
soon as it gets on fun you're gonna
think what what's the point then you'll
stop and then you get out the habit but
if you've got a business behind there
it's fun you do it because you love
doing it but you're also getting paid to
do it so make as much money as you
possibly can as an influencer without
being inauthentic or incongruent
I think when you go neat and going down
different avenues I don't think it's as
hard as people think it is exaggerated I
mean goodness me the world is saturated
with seven billion people which means
there's more people trying to do it
there's also more eyeballs waiting for
you to do to watch yeah
and the best time start is 20 years ago
and the second best
[Music]